The war in Ukraine continues despite the Minsk
ceasefire agreement because it is rooted deeply
in ideological, geostrategic, and domestic
political goals of Vladimir Putin, Russia’s
likely president–for life.
Russia has violated two ceasefire agreements.
It continues to send troops, arms and heavy
equipment into Ukraine in support of its proxies,
the so-called “separatists.”
And Russia will continue this war until it
achieves all of its goals there–or until
Vladimir Putin finds the domestic political
costs too high and will be forced to scale
down and to compromise.
So what is Putin seeking to achieve in Ukraine
and why?
Ideologically, Putin fancies himself the “gatherer”
of historically Russian lands.
In his worldview, Russia is not only a country—it
is the center of a unique Eurasian civilization,
distinct from both Europe and Asia.
Policies like the “Russian World” and
the “Eurasian Union” seek to fulfill this
ideal: not a new Soviet Union but a Russia
militarily, politically and economically dominant
over much of Eurasia with a veto power over
the neighboring countries’ foreign policies
and domestic political arrangements as well.
So a Europe­-bound Ukraine is a key, perhaps
fatal, obstacle to such a plan.
Geostrategically Putin sees this new Russia
as a counterbalance to the United States and
the West, which, in his view, not only are
bent on world domination but first and foremost
are constantly scheming against Russia with
a goal of taking away its sovereignty.
Domestic political considerations, however,
are by far the most important factor in Putin’s
policy in Ukraine.
Before Russia’s “Ukrainian adventure”,
Putin’s popularity was at record lows.
Promises of reforming and modernizing the
economy went unfulfilled, and Russians were
left with the same corrupt, oil­-dependent
system that they have had for years.
By contrast, the patriotic mobilization and
the anti­-West hysteria, unleashed by the
state controlled television, have made the
President into the defender of the Motherland,
accounting for his astronomic ratings – which
is the only reliable part of the regime’s
legitimacy.
But it is a two-edged political sword.
If Russia is seen to have achieved anything
short of a total victory in Ukraine, there
is likely to be a sharp downfall in Putin’s
personal popularity.
This should be especially troubling for the
regime, given that Russia’s economy is sliding
into full-blown economic crisis, with the
ruble plummeting and inflation heating up.
So Putin needs a victory that would include
not just a permanent dismemberment of Ukraine
but also its destabilization and ultimately
the replacement of the current pro­-European
regime in Kiev with a Russian puppet.
So, what can the West do about this?
Given Russia’s military advantage over Ukraine,
a quick victory on the battlefield is out
of the question.
Instead, a patient, long-term strategy is
needed—one which would include, but not
be limited to, arming and training Ukrainian
forces in order to raise the domestic costs
of Putin’s aggression: both in treasure
and, most importantly, in blood.
Putin will in Ukraine for as long as he needs
to.
So if the West is serious in thwarting his
plans, it needs to have just as much patience
and resolve.